hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 51 hört zu und spricht nach
am sonntag war ich bei lisa
am sonntag war ich bei lisa sie hat eine
neue wohnung in einem wohnhaus
sie hat eine neue wohnung in einem
wohnhaus
ihre wohnung ist im elften stock
ihre wohnung ist im elften stock auf
ihrem
schon hat man eine schöne aussicht über
die altstadt
auf ihrem
schon hat man eine
eine aussicht über die altstadt misst
der kühlschrank ist leer
ist der kühlschrank ist leer war heute
niemand im supermarkt war
niemand im supermarkt
jetzt hat der supermarkt schon
geschlossen es ist schon 21 uhr
jetzt haben
markt schon geschlossen es ist schon 21
uhr
ich habe
ich habe hunger
die tankstelle ist noch geöffnet
die tanks
ist noch geöffnet
komm wir fahren zur tankstelle
dort kann man 24 stunden lang einkaufen
das ist mir zu umständlich und dauert zu
lange
danach
noch kochen danach müssen wir noch
kochen
ich gehe ins restaurant
ich muss dieses paket von bailando
zurückschicken
ich muss dieses paket vom bailando
weißt du ob es vor der post parkplätze
gibt
gibt ja es gibt parkplätze
ja es gibt parkplätze aber jetzt hat die
post schon geschlossen
aber jetzt
hat die post schon geschlossen geh
morgen auf die post
geh morgen auf die post
wir müssen endlich mal das glas und
metall entsorgen
weißt du wo es eine entsorgungsstelle
gibt
auf den parkplätzen neben dem zwingli
platz gibt es eine entsorgungsstelle
auf den parkplätzen neben
dem zwingli platz gibt es eine
entsorgungsstelle
dort kann man das alte glas und metall
entsorgen
dort kann man
das alte glas und metall entsorgen
wer
positionen
ich gehe bewegung wohin
in den supermarkt
den supermarkt
die bar die
das restaurant
ins restaurant ins restaurant
ich bin position wo in
dem supermarkt
im supermarkt im supermarkt
der bau der bahn
dem restaurant den
restaurant im restaurant
im restaurant
ich stelle bewegung wohin
auf den parkplatz auf den parkplatz
in die k
indycar
schön
hinter das haus
hinter das haus mein auto steht position
wo
auf dem parkplatz auf dem parkplatz in
der garage
asche
in der garage
hinter dem haus
hallo julian hallo barbara was machst du
ich bin gerade im fitnesscenter
dann treffen wir uns heute abend
das konzert beginnt um 20 uhr ich hole
dich um 1930 ab dann können wir zusammen
ans konzert gehen
gehen wir vorher noch etwas essen ich
kann leider nicht ich bin noch im büro
und muss heute länger arbeiten
ok dann bis später bis später
nadine wohin gehst du in die ferien
ich weiß es noch nicht ich gehe aber
sicher irgendwo an den strand du hast
recht ich liebe auch strandferien
andreas wieso dauert das so lange keine
ahnung der mann vor uns liegt
anscheinend sein ganzes erspartes kommt
schau mal die bankangestellte sie zählt
schon seit fünf minuten das geld richte
doch endlich mal dein online banking ein
ich habe es satt immer auf der bank zeit
zu verlieren
du hast recht es ist wirklich an der
zeit aber ich traue diesem internet
nicht
hallo hallo thomas wie lange ist das her
sicher schon drei jahre wie schnell die
zeit vergeht ja ich wollte dich immer
mal anrufen aber kein problem edeka hast
du jetzt zeit was uns etwas trinken und
ein bisschen plaudern
ja aber ich habe nur knapp eine stunde
zeit super komm wir gehen gleich in die
paar hier es gibt so viel zu erzählen
kritik kann ich ihnen helfen ja ich
suche das medikament tamiflu 300 das
haben wir hier
es ist aber rezeptpflichtig wir dürfen
in der apotheke keine starken
medikamente ohne rezept verkaufen
kein problem ja klar hier ist mein
rezept vielen dank ich brauche auch noch
ihren ausweis bitte hier bitte 300